foreign
[Music]
I'll watch your whole family eat dinner
so let's get some smelling salts in the
system first you want to yeah
[Music]
I'm excited dude
if you're just born with giant tits you
just hit the genetic Lottery
that's crap like imagine if you put on
like
a shirt right but every every couple
days a shirt was like guess what you
don't have a shirt on oh wow you're kind
of a [__] you're fake I don't know dude
I'll tell you this one time I was
walking down the street in New York and
they had a deaf group or whatever like a
Gaggle or whatever I don't know what
it's called but they got together and
they were outside of a bar talking and
I'm walking up and I'm like I thought
maybe like the world would like shut off
or something I couldn't hear because I'm
seeing all these people interacting but
nobody was there was no sound oh yeah I
met a few of those too yeah oh yeah it's
very frustrating because you're like I
thought you were nice I saw you on TV
you're nice I'm just trying to say hi
and you're [__] [__] to me I'm trying
to think of what else has been going on
by the way I have a 13 half inch deck
you got this big old dick all on you um
you can actually get it from your
parents I don't know why you have to
basically hold your dick up like this
when you walk over to the bathroom walk
around to get used to it but in the
beginning you kind of have to just walk
like this
yeah
um
what else were we talking about but
dicks big dicks oh big old dicks yeah
imagine it's bringing a bag in and
people like what's in the bag you're
like my nuts every guy loves big tits
they all love them they have no use for
them they just want to squeeze them just
want to suck on them some of them are so
big though yeah you can get too big just
like a dick but it'll make the level
that it drops off to it's too much of a
drop look at that look at his butt look
at his butt yeah click on that when it's
pretty steep it's like oh man this feels
sometimes scary yeah I know what you're
saying probably if you're naked what is
giant hog uh do you think like 13 and a
half inches I would imagine girls like
don't swipe right on you dude
I would hate having that much wiener I
feel like really
you don't know until you have it you
just have to find the right gals you
know the caller daddy podcast yeah you
know what's crazy about them they're
only horny like that for like a month
yeah I think there's something about
that people have an extra wiener that
makes anything
it makes you angry like the world's not
fair well that's how flat chested girls
feel and when other girls walk by with
giant tits oh damn they can manipulate a
young fella duh y'all have fun the dick
is hard and their dick flops up and down
when they scream
their dick flops and they start pissing
all over themselves they piss all over
themselves dude that's why sometimes I
think like I would hate to have like one
of those long wieners like because
you've gone back to that what the [__]
is wrong with you
I don't know who knows I mean who knows
who knows I don't know I used to have
piranhas yeah of course you did man who
doesn't think you did
propellers will [__] up a dolphin oh
yeah my friend Dave got pushed off a
boat in his and he got hit by it when we
went we went over him he got pushed off
the front oh Jesus
I'm not sure he wasn't that great to
start off with but he that was the first
guy he ever met yeah I think I just got
so nerd I think just like I would be so
nervous around them you know and um but
it should be if they're not trained well
and I think there's something about
their smell
Google that he was incredible you know I
fart and you like waft up the smell like
what is that Jesus Christ like whoa
that's a nice feeling I'm gonna have to
try a little bit tonight I think finally
[__] yeah boy it's not fresh but it's
good enough Here Comes Santa Claus right
down Santa Claus Lane take a sniff oh
wow I don't think it's bad I don't feel
I always just judge like how do I feel
how do I feel after yeah and after I
feel fine there's nothing better than
being in a pool talking to somebody and
peeing at the same time I can't Point
there's a lot of things better than that
yeah you're right you're right you're
right there's a lot of things going on I
mean it's not even in the top thousand
out of all the good things the smell of
fresh baked bread is better than that
all right baby dude without even eating
it
I mean yeah if you got a [__] kitchen
or whatever yeah but still if some 40
year old lady [__] a 17 year old boy
I'm like all right dude how was it is
she crazy what's going on
if she's hot and he's not coerced and
drugged who cares especially in the
South the deal's a deal yeah you're
right we're better than that don't do
that again hey stop blowing kids I wish
we could tell how much dogs love us or
not you know my dog is the best dog the
golden retriever they're the best pet oh
a lot of people if they didn't have a
dad they would have a dog you know
that's scary for a homophobe first time
I ever even met a uh indoor dog it was I
don't know a dog could even be indoors
I was always worried about my dog
getting out my dog Frank Sinatra dude
one time
um I had a babysitter and they had they
found a guy under their bed in their
house and what a scary thing oh my God
she came up the stairs and uh she could
see under the bed because the bedroom
door was open when she walked down the
stairs and she saw a guy under there oh
Jesus what did they do and then called
the police and he was mentally unwell
ain't it weird that that one fish we
decided to just [__] can up all the
time like you can't turn into sandwiches
everything yeah like tuna salad tuna
this tuna that's all tuna yeah tuna
really got the it's gotten the brunt of
it huh oh my God I bet other fish like
oh thank God we're not tuna yeah yeah I
mean they they're like the most canned
fish ever that's unreal
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]
foreign